[Music]
is rotten tomatoes wrong
about thor the dark world it is the 10th
year anniversary
of the original thor well the one that
came out in 2011 and we also are getting
very excited about that loki series
that's gonna drop sooner
rather than later welcome to the show
everyone my name is mark ellis you
probably know me
our great amazing host jacqueline coley
is enjoying her vacation a well-earned
vacation i may say
my whole life is a vacation she actually
works hard and if you saw any of the
oscars you know
how great she was at covering that start
to finish
so she's off somewhere and she might be
in asgard i'm not actually sure where
she is right now
but she's jet setting she's flying
somewhere and having a blast i hope
but in her stead we have an amazing
co-host in his own right because he
is actually an asgardian i read that
wrong he's actually an australian
but close enough he is also the
editor-in-chief
of rotten tomatoes that's right our
returning home alone
ii lost the new york champion joel
mears joel hello how have you
been i've been pretty well since uh
christmas time when we talked home alone
and i'm proud to graduate from
guest to co-host uh
you are right jacqueline does an awesome
job and i'm hoping i can be
just one inch of what she would provide
for this show today and uh yeah i'm
great i'm so excited to talk about thor
my fellow asgardian uh chris hemsworth
uh in the lead in that film
national hero so very excited to get
stuck into it
it's great and i'm not sure how the the
debate amongst the best hemsworth
brother is in
your native land but over here i'm
pretty sure chris is winning at the
moment i mean
his brothers have done some big things
but it's still chris hemsworth gig
right he's the lead hemsworth he is the
lead hemsworth uh there was a someone
asked me the day
is everyone in some way related to the
hemsworth and i think this is this is
kind of true and i count myself as like
the 99th hemsworth if we're going
rankings maybe
um but yeah no i think chris is still
number one liam a close second
guy from westworld third and
uh no they're they're a great family
grew up in farming uh tasmanian
region i know why i'm saying that but
interesting fact uh
we love the hemsworth if you need a tour
guide and go into australia recruit joel
mears because i think someone in his
family owns a bar back there so that's
always good news and that would be good
news
for me if i'm traveling there or for our
special guest who is built like an
asgardian we're gonna get to him in just
a minute but right now
joel uh the floor is your sir let's talk
about thor the dark world in terms of
tomato mint excuse me tomato meter and
what is this movie about you get to give
us the score and the synopsis
at your ready sir right yes uh tomato
meter because we are doing asgardian
accents today
um it has a tomato meter score of 66
which is fresh uh but only fresh
slightly
but it does make thor the dark world the
lowest rated movie in the entire marvel
cinematic universe
on the tomato meter it is one percent
lower
than the incredible hulk uh which is
the second lowest uh and then we get up
into the 70s and some and some better
films
uh better reviewed films at least the
audience score is higher it's 75
so audiences liking dark world a little
more but
yeah 66 it's pretty pretty low
it's gonna be fun to revisit too because
that audience score is just one percent
shy of what the original thor in 2011
was and again we're celebrating the
10-year anniversary of that film
and so when you look at thor the dark
world we talk about it in context of
movies itself but also in terms of the
mcu because we're just so spoiled with
how great those films have been and so
this one a little bit lower but like you
said
still fresh on the meter and the next
question
is not the easiest one in the world to
do i've been dreading this since i found
out i had to do it
that's why we give you the job and i
just get to kick back this is my mini
vacation because joel is now going to
tell us
what thor the dark world is about
thankfully with this movie they stop
every sort of three scenes to explain
what's going on
on a blackboard or in a book or or
something with a flashback so that was
pretty helpful
um but essentially what this film is
about
is many millennia or hundreds of years
ago the asgardians fought the dark elves
the dark elves want to plunge the
universe into darkness for
some reason we're not really told why
except that they're called dark elves
um they they want to do this you by
using something called the ether
which it will turn out is the reality
stone for infinity stone watchers out
there
um they fail their entire species
essentially is destroyed
a couple are left behind including the
incredibly charismatic
malakith but they're off into a slumber
the ether is hidden
in earth uh for some reason uh cut to
present day 2013 um uk jane foster
natalie portman discovers the ether
she accidentally becomes the ether or
has the ether
consumed into her which makes her eyes
dark
and that's about all it does besides
making her faint and give her really
good hair at most times
uh thor feels uh the ether i think and
comes down to earth and he's like hey
jane
brings her back up to asgard to try and
help her because she keeps fainting and
stuff
uh meanwhile malakith maliketh um
with the excellent braid sort of wakes
up and he's like oh ether i want to
plunge the world into darkness again
there's something happening called the
assimilation or the convergence
i think they switch between those two
terms at times that's going to help him
plunge the world of
darkness he goes after the ether and
asgard attack on asgard
stuff happens meanwhile loki uh who's
just you know done a lot of terrible
things in new york is
uh hannibal lectering in the basement of
the big castle in asgard
um things happen he comes out he joins
the crew they try to save the world
from some elves um darcy's back
uh eric solvag's back a lot happens
but also nothing happens so it's it's
quite an interesting uh
interesting film in that regard uh
there's portals there's also portals
there's there are definitely portals so
that was a very uh
well well-thought-out thorough synopsis
of a movie that is not
easy to explain because you can go very
surface level with it which is how you
close down
a lot happens and also nothing really
happens but it does get deep into some
of the mythology particularly with
asgard and so
there is a lot to talk about we're gonna
do all that break down our favorite or
maybe least favorite
movie scenes with thor the dark world in
particular and then once we get to our
behind the scenes segment
we're gonna extrapolate that into the
breadth of the mcu and maybe if we put
on our rose tinted glasses and look back
knowing what we know now after end game
does that improve
for the dark world all of that and more
but first our special guest well you
know what joel we actually have two
special guests today because
returning to the producerial chair
that was magnificently held by christian
rubicon the last couple weeks
is producie lucy lucy you are
back welcome back luce hello thank you
i'm
so happy to be back and see your
beautiful shining faces
and talking about today some of the
sexiest men alive
coffee well thank you mark and joel um
thor and loki and anthony hopkins don't
forget
mark are you the loki to my thor i'm
definitely not
gonna call myself here i think that's
pretty presumptuous of me
yeah but i'm not gonna call myself thor
in front of the editor-in-chief so
yeah i am gonna be the loki or maybe the
i'll i'll be the jane joel you just tell
me what role you want you to play
i'm the eric selvec just running around
sort of pantsless
at stonehenge um but we should we let's
introduce and
our other guest uh yes he's gonna be
waiting in the wings foster he's gonna
be you know what i'll i'll be cat
dancing
he's the thest of us i think he i think
he takes the thought i think he's got
the hammer
i think he's the one who can lift the
hammer he's certainly the one that came
because he's got the guns
you look at those biceps he is the host
of coy cast and the host of comic book
shopping basically everywhere you want
to get your comic book movie news
you can go to this man online or really
in person seriously you can have nine
hour conversations with him
about all things comic book news i feel
like i'm introducing motivational
speaker matt foley he's been drinking
coffee in the basement for the last six
hours
and now he is here on the show returning
once again
a fresh member of the ketchup crew coy
hello koi i love your decorative pillows
i i thought iron man should come today
but i also i brought wolverine just in
case there's any sort of crossover
and uh because it's the world of thor
we've got loki but the cinematic loki
the the in
movie movie loki i'm ready i'm strapped
in
it is so great to have you because you
really are so
adept at walking people through the
sometimes
thick murky waters of comic book movie
canon and how things
tie in and why maybe if we didn't get a
scene initially we can take a step back
and say oh well now that makes more
sense so
with thor the dark world i want to start
with you koi simply just give us
your reasoning for if you feel like
rotten tomatoes is
wrong about throw the dark world you
know i do
feel like rotten tomatoes is wrong but
it's within a very specific margin
and i think that's really interesting
because of the way rotten tomatoes
allocate scores is you're looking at you
know you you summarize a film by looking
at a percentage which is
an assortment of other people's opinions
but i would say this needs to be
just to scotch up so it reaches that
like c minus mark you know if you look
at the
the american academia school rating i
would say this needs to be in the low
70s instead of the mid 60s
only because it's not as close to a
failure as people might perceive it as
but i would still argue it's in the
bottom tier of marvel but i would say
the bottom three marvel films are all at
that 70 to 73 percentile
so i would up it a bit because i don't
think it's quite as fair
where it lands but i do see how it's the
lower caliber of the marvel films but
that's saying something because
25 properties in i think the worst
marvel's done is a cc minus and that's
impressive
it's a magnificent accomplishment
probably
unmatched in history and i don't know if
we'll ever see the likes of something
like that again and so joel
coy thinks that the movie deserves to be
just a little fresher than it is it's
standing a little too close to the
dumpster for his taste
joel mears editor-in-chief is rotten
tomatoes
wrong about thor the dark world well
rotten tomatoes is never wrong i have to
say that
as someone sitting in my my my throne
here um all i heard from from koi was
that the tomato meter should be the
grade by which
american scholastic achievement is
designated
and that rather that's what i'm thinking
from that i think we can branch out now
this is a this is an opportunity
business-wise
um anyway sorry i just got my little
notes there is rotten tomatoes wrong i
joke rotten tomatoes i disagree with the
score sometimes and in this case i think
rotten tomatoes is absolutely
wrong uh for on multiple levels though
i'm like
because i watch this movie and i'm in
certain scenes and i'm like
ronta motors is so wrong because this
movie should be 90
at this moment that i'm watching it and
then 20 minutes later i'm watching it
i'm like whoa rotten tomatoes is wrong
this movie should be hovering around the
10
because this is bad so it's kind of like
this
i found you know to be honest with you i
don't remember when i first saw this
film because
i think it's probably among the mcu
movies one of the somewhat more
forgettable ones
sorry spoiler alert about how i might
feel about it but re-watching it it was
like a yo-yo
i was sort of like this is awesome this
is terrible i love this i hate this
um so that's sort of where i am i think
i'm wrong
maybe the pendulum swings and lands at
around 66 but uh yeah
it's right and wrong depending on which
part of the film i'm watching
that is so funny you say that because
you know the movie as a whole
we've talked about films and we even
talked about one last week with 2019's
aladdin where
there were moments of just pure
greatness and i thought it was amazing
but yet i still would agree with the
tomato meter on that it's 57
at the time of that recording here 66
coy
i'm with you i don't think it's a wide
margin but i'm going in the opposite
direction i think that we can make this
movie
borderline fresh even more and i might
even say dip
into rotten at around that 57 58 59
percent
so yes i'm gonna say rotten tomatoes is
wrong but again it's it's not by
a lot it's just that this movie i think
is one of the weaker of the mcu
but when you say that it's like saying
oh
well i mean that pizza i had was good
but it's just not as good as new york
pizza well of course it's not as good as
new york pizza it's still pizza it's
still bread and cheese and tomato sauce
it's delicious
so if i think about thor the dark world
upon re-watching it i had a good time
i had a very good time watching it and i
think that sometimes and we'll talk
about this more in the behind the scenes
section of the show today
we just compare it to similar things
and because it's in the mcu it just has
that designation of being like the 20th
or the 23rd best mcu movie
but come on the mcu has so many great
movies so
i'm just not sure we're being fair
arbiters but that is why
we are here today and we appreciate all
of our listeners and viewers
being along for the ride so one of the
ways that we get warmed up here on the
show is we take a break from talking and
we listen to our expert review curation
manager at rotten tomatoes
tim ryan he's going to tell us what the
critics were saying
at the time of the release of thor the
dark world so
tim at you're ready let's queue up two
minutes with tim
[Music]
thank you mark so here it is the worst
reviewed movie
in the marvel cinematic universe and
it's still
fresh when thor the dark world came out
a lot of the critics
basically felt like the visuals were as
strong as ever but the plot was a little
bit clunky
that overall it's fine and it's
moderately fun but it didn't achieve the
heights of previous marvel films
the stakes were lower this time out
which added
a general lack of pretension to the
whole thing
but also sometimes it felt like it
didn't have the gravitas of previous
films
all that being said as loki tom
hiddleston stole every scene he was in
playing the role to the hilt with wit
and sarcasm
and that family dynamic between him and
thor is at the heart of the movie
it's at 66 on the tomato meter with 283
reviews and it's got a 75
audience score it is one point ahead of
the incredible hulk which is at 67
but well below thor at 77 and thor
ragnarok at 93 percent
so what did the critics have to say in a
fresh review chris or
the atlantic wrote though hardly a
must-see thor the dark world is better
than the original
a looser loopier hybrid of science
fiction and fantasy
powered by a pair of magnetic
performances and levened with a number
of truly witty moments
however in a rotten review shabra gupta
of the indian express wrote
loki is the only character who makes
himself new and interesting
when he's around sora the dark world
becomes a different film altogether
you wish there was more of him the rest
of it is metal clanking
rotten tomatoes critic's consensus is it
may not be the finest film to come from
the marvel universe but thor the dark
world still offers plenty of the humor
and high stakes action that fans have
come to expect
so anyway that's thor the dark world
i'm gonna kick it back to mark he's a
friend
from work back to you guys
and you are my friend from work tim uh
thank you so much for that
yeah i mean you talk about loki and
stealing every scene he's in
is not only because it's the great tom
hiddleston playing it but it's also
because
that's what loki does he infiltrates
your movie and he becomes the best part
of it even if he's nowhere to be seen
on the poster or above the movie title
itself
and so with the critics i think that one
of the questions we have to start off
our movie scenes with which we're going
to get to in just a sec
is in in the broad scope of things is
this
the worst mcu movie and it's a question
that feels so negative because you're
talking about the worst of something but
because it's the mcu it may still not be
all that bad so i think it's time to tee
up movie talk
so okay let's get right into this fellas
do you koi
have a specific movie that you hold up
whether it's the dark world or something
else
that you say that is the one that is the
weakest link
in the mcu canon i i do and i do think
it's this one
but i don't think it's as bad to have
something
this good be the worst so i think that's
what we're gonna be talking about but i
definitely think the things that this
one did
wrong strengthened the mcu going forward
i think this was
a great learning curve for the entire
universe okay joel do you agree with
that is this the weakest strand in the
mcu dna or do you have another specific
movie that you're like no no that's the
one
i mean well first of all i think you
know we can we can get negative on the
mcu
they they've they've had their flowers
you know they've done some they've had
some pretty good years you know
uh both on the tomato meter at the box
office and in dominating the entire
pop culture so i'm happy to say throw a
few uh arrows their way
um but i actually don't think this is
the worst mcu movie and actually
you know before i didn't really say
where i landed on whether rotten
tomatoes is wrong i ultimately would
give
personally this film in the sort of high
40s um because i think the things that
gets wrong are
quite fundamental um about you know
we'll get into that but
uh you know i can't forgive a lot of
iron man 2. um
i find that just a incoherent bloated
mess
um the incredible hulk does very little
for me
i think it shares a lot of the flaws
that this film has in some ways
um and i'm not super into captain marvel
because i think the
uh i think that film structurally did
something that didn't work
um and i think did a disservice to that
character
so and i think there's a lot going on
that's great in that film with telos and
whatnot but um
yeah i think i'd probably say i have a
better time
watching this and would want to re-watch
this film
above a handful of other mcu films
again pizza it's all pizza it's all
gonna make me
you know full at the end of the day um
but there is better pizza
some pizza is better i'm sitting in new
york mark i know this i know hey i'm out
here in l.a and i'm just heating up my
bagel bites and still
enjoying them thoroughly let's get into
the scenes
let's talk about this koi is there a
scene for you
that thinks this okay this is why i
watch this movie and i say
come on it's got to be at least in the
70s rotten tomatoes so i think it's
interesting we have the exact same
bottom four
uh but for for similar reasons this is
the way i look at the mcu
is it's it's a series it's ongoing it's
like comic books they're monthly they
come out often they build a world
i think this needed to be dark and i
think it needed to figure out its empire
strikes back tone that a lot of phase
two is
if you look at phase two you've got age
of ultron substantially darker than
avengers which is the last time i was on
we talked about how
that i actually had the opposite opinion
i think it needed to be a little lower
for
learning curve i think the learning
curve of this one benefited the mcu as a
series because it took risks
the character of thor in the comic books
is super convoluted he's written a
hundred different ways
so much so that when they rebooted the
marvel universe in the ultimate universe
which is a lot of what these movies are
based off of
ultimate spider-man as a foundational
character for tom hall and spider-man
the ultimate is a lot of the espionage
feel that the movies took on
they didn't know what to do with thor to
the point where they made him a guy that
you didn't know was crazy or not
about his mythology you don't know if
thor is a crazy hobo
half the time in that comic book and
they used that in the first thor movie
because
the writer mark millar or the comic book
you could tell he was trying to shape
where he would exist in our modern world
so i thought it was a very bold choice
to make a thor sequel that was so
different from the shakespearean
allegories and and grandiose flavor and
just submerge him in darkness
give it that game of thrones feel but
while doing that upping the production
value this movie looks a lot less
inexpensive
this movie has more than just asgard
going for it and
it took the risk of being an extremely
dark film while the mcu had been largely
bright up to date so
i would say the things it stumbled with
weren't to the benefit of the mcu as a
whole
so it deserves to be higher up in the
rating okay so
what what's a specific scene that you
would say that's why i love
thor the dark world that's why i can go
back and revisit it
and it's on a par with the best of the
mcu there's two that
stand out and the first is the cameo
with chris evans as captain america
yeah because him as loki so good it gave
chris evans like the chance to be
boston's chris evans it gave chris evans
the chance to be like
sarcastically american oh this is much
better
whoa costume's a bit much
so tight but the confidence i can feel
the righteousness surging
hey you want to have a rousing
discussion about truth honor
patriotism god bless him
and it was a really beautiful moment of
what the universe could have done with
captain america it gave us a little bit
of that john walker it gave us a little
bit of that
what america is seen as two people
outside of it and loki playing that
braggadocious
full of confidence while still somehow
charming chris evans gave us an insight
to the greater mcu
without tarnishing the stakes living
within thor one of the beautiful things
about these movies is they find creative
ways to be like why wouldn't he just
call iron man why wouldn't he just call
his avenger friends
and that gave us a taste of what it
would have been like to have a team-up
moment like in the comic books
gave us the taste of the greater
universe without sacrificing the
integrity of the stakes
while being extremely funny in a very
dark movie that moment of levity was
incredibly important
and the other would be anything with
lady siff i think lady siff was one of
the very first strong female characters
in the mcu she's our wonder woman
she's got an incredibly captivating
story with very limited screen time
and she is someone that would make sense
as a love interest for thor and it's
used really interestingly because
she isn't ever a damsel in distress and
at times natalie portman is
so it strengthens the love triangle by
having natalie portman
be the the object of his torn nature
between being a god
and going back and being immortal on
earth and being a god of earth
so having a god that you fall in love
with so quickly
because of how great jamie alexander
played this role i think lady siff
one of the most underutilized characters
in the mcu but she did so much with so
little in this film
that you actually are like bro she's
right there what are you doing for
natalie portman's incredible
lady siff's right there so it's a really
interesting character yeah
i've got thoughts on this i'm like i i
i'm
i am i'm raring to go about this lady
sif business
oh this is going to be good then i was
just simply going to say that
thor for a lot of this movie is torn
between like him being a god on asgard
which is what he's used to
and just this like city of angels thing
where he's just falling in love with
this human
so the choice is between jane foster
and lady sith or at least it would
appear that he's emotionally torn
between those two
you have thoughts on lady sith well i
think
my thoughts on ladies if speak to what i
think is one of the fundamental issues
with the film it's
the film has so much potential and the
characters and the stories they're in
have so much potential and yet it just
never goes anywhere with them
so like ladies if i agree i love her i
love jamie alexander
but where is she like she shows up in
the beginning
then she comes in and sort of gives a
sideways glance
that's the donut that's the level of the
love triangle we get then she basically
completely disappears
until the end along with that other
really interesting troupe of people
now featuring zachary levy levi um levi
um with natalie portman's character
again
you have this extraordinarily smart
we're told
um scientist who is imbued with this
sort of
ether um and there's i'm just thinking
dark phoenix go dark phoenix or
at least do something with these powers
that you're given
and then nothing we do we don't get
basically anything from her
and it feels like at all these points
these interesting things could have
happened with potential
but they just never take off so that's
my
my main issue with it and if i'm
thinking about a film
i mean a scene from the movie that
illustrates why
my main issues sort of separate from
that is basically anything involving
malaketh
because i think this character like the
dark elf
sort of um law seems to be compelling
seems to have a lot of potential um but
we
and his mission is is is massive like
his ambitions are huge right
darken the universe but we never
actually get a moment where we realize
what's personally motivating him we
barely get to see him
sort of talk about his his mission
have come so far as guardian death would
have come to you
soon enough not by your hand your
universe was never meant to be
your world and your family will be
extinguished
it's not unfairness in what he wants to
achieve right but thanos we know
has a philosophy a guiding principle
that malaketh is just a guy in a braid
and i can't i just i'm not into it again
potential potential potential snuffed
out
see by this point i i was kind of in
tune with getting to
pull for the heroes so easily in the mcu
because the villains
even the cooler ones aesthetically you
just
they didn't quite live up to match their
superhero foils
and so when malaccus shows up it's like
all right look we got to defeat a dark
elf now do i want to come across him
at santa's workshop no but are we gonna
be able to take care of business
yes that's me walking into the movie but
then the opening scene is one of my
favorites
is because it's just this cool action
scene that's setting up
what we are to expect and so when you
get that
exposition which is clearly what that
scene is set up for it
it looks really cool and so it it but it
also shows us just how fearful we should
be
of malachi's intent of wanting to darken
the world because this is what it's
going to look like you know why why does
why does he want to do it though
he might be my vibe i was just like it
might just be a cryotherapy fan
core do you have an answer for that is
there a specific reason that you can
find
in thor the dark world that even hints
at why
malikith has this intense motivation so
this is one of those tricky things where
it's removing comic lore from comic
movie and it's really hard to separate
it's like reading a history book and
being like forget that going into the
movie based on the history book
the comic books have so much mythology
at the dark elves malakith has
decades of issues of why he wants to do
these things so it's hard to remove that
but
in the film they never give more than
the opening
odin speech about his his goals i kind
of tied it to laffy
and the the ice realms and those things
because in the comic books there is
some um team-up aspects between those
two characters
but in this film i think it's just a
matter of how the elves feel betrayed
because the elves the dark elves are are
separated from the regular race of elves
and they don't really explain that well
and so they want to put the world into
darkness as kind of a revenge on feeling
ostracized and put in the corner and
being these creatures that are not
spoken of so
none of that really gets across but i to
what you were saying
at this point in the mcu this was right
before winter soldier it was actually
funny i have it on blu-ray so i watched
it and the winter soldier trailer
is what you watch before the movie that
was the first film in the mcu that
didn't suffer from the the grey minion
problem like the avengers had the gray
guys who fought with the the space hole
and
and the first set of the phase one you
know you've got thor ending in new
mexico
because it's like okay we've spent a lot
of money on asgard
what if it's in the middle of nowhere we
have one that can blow up like there's a
lot of phase one issues with the
villains where they've got to kind of
either put them off to the side to save
on money or we have to clone one
special cgi character a lot so we
forgave the villains in the first phase
a lot more
but when you're looking at this film by
itself i do think it's unfair to have
this near the same rating as a
spider-man 3 or an x-men last stand
which it is
spider-man 3 is at 63 percent x-men the
last stands at 58.
this is a lot better than ten percent
better than last stand
this is a lot better than three percent
better than spider-man three and and
what's cool about rotten tomatoes is it
it colorizes black and white photos like
world war one photos colorized give you
a more
conscious grasp of the experience and
rotten tomatoes aggregates a black and
white scale into color
so i would argue that this oh i'm
stealing that
sorry i was gonna say for my next for my
next press interview i'm definitely you
guys guys give me rotten
i'm not even remotely crediting you
either just come on god this episode's
never going to air because it's like i
have this great idea aggregate and color
there's someone knocking on your door to
take you out now
you take the sd card out of the camera
this is all gone spidey cat i'm sorry
but it aggregates color to make you feel
like you're you're part of the
experience in a different format so
i would argue that a score needing to
reflect the experience as compared to
other superhero films is fair
as opposed to just being within the mcu
so that's why i think it needs to be
higher because
yes it's 10 years more recent than your
spider-man's and your x-men the last
stands but it also takes a lot of bolder
chances
beyond the villain the villain doesn't
necessarily work but the
the world building in that opening scene
the star wars like space fighters all
the darkness that allows it to be
it's like kevin feige was starting to be
able to listen to
mcu fans about some of the villain
problems he was starting to listen about
things looking like they were made for
tv
and this was a really bold step in the
direction that allowed for everything
post-winner soldier this winter soldier
and age of ultron got us to have endgame
and infinity war
beyond the storytelling elements of the
family this movie needed to happen for
us to get there
and some of those character motivations
that we talk about not just with
malekith but with thor
particularly him and loki together i
felt like the movie missed
the opportunity here and this is why i
don't think it's one of the better mcu
films
look it's not fair to compare any movie
on any merit
to the empire strikes back but
inevitably if we talk about a sequel
and that sequel gets darker in tone we
say oh well it's like the empire strikes
back but the empire strikes back
succeeds
on how much we care about the
relationships whether it's luke
developing a friendship with yoda or
it's han and leia getting together
with this movie i feel like
it realized that we just don't quite
have anything
to glum onto the brother dynamic is the
closest to that and apparently upon test
screenings
that's why the audience reacted like you
ain't killing off loki we love him in
this movie and so
you got to get more loki in there but
what i really think missed the point it
just sort of
fell back on its laurels of well of
course it's going to be emotional when
you lose
your mom they they just play on that so
much and i think it's just a little bit
i don't know i don't want to say
manipulative but it just feels a little
unfair to be like okay well we're just
going to experience the mom dying renee
russo's so good i was so upset
when when we lose her and naturally is
going to fortify a character but i feel
like we've been there so many times with
movies that
we could have just had something else in
its place or maybe
earlier in the movie to get our
characters particularly our heroes
motivated and into that hero mode
it's a manipulative moment in a lazy
trope
like it's a trope that we've seen far
too often
where mothers sisters wives etc are
killed to unite uh
you know i look with three men here but
this is a problem that happens with
films right they
they use the women to motivate the men
in this way uh and just
so people i don't think i mentioned in
the synopsis that um
uh rene russo's character frida friga
apologies um dies uh
and she does and i think it is an
awesome scene in some ways because we
get to see her pull out the sword and
fight um
the elf and then unfortunately she is
killed
um but yeah i thought that as a as a way
to sort of force those two boys together
was really lazy um and unfortunate
and robbed us of a great potential
character who could have been another
strong woman rather than someone whose
potential was again snuffed out
in this film um that said
the movie really does work when loki and
thor are together
and i agree with koi that that scene
with the um the chris evans cameo when
they're walking through the palace
it's sort of they've just gotten out
they've got this plan uh they're
shape-shifting it's all witty bander
and uh i believe was written by joss
whedon who was brought in to sort of
punch up the script and give the film
some comedy uh is brilliant
and from then on i'm with them even
though i was really annoyed at what got
them
together koi you have the final word in
this segment do you feel like that was
just
as joel said and i intimated that it was
just sort of a manipulative lazy trope
to have the mom die and that's the only
thing that could get the brothers
together i know they're not seeing eye
to eye after everything that happened in
new york but
is do you feel like that was the only
thing that could get them
united again or do you think that we
could have done something else and
kept a great strong female character
alive in the mcu
i do think it is a it is a waste of
renee russo anytime you lose renee russo
uh
obviously we know with the benefit of
hindsight not talking about other movies
too much but they were able to bring her
back in a really creative way especially
using deleted scenes from this film
but i i can't think of another thing in
canon that necessarily would have
brought them together i i see the
manipulation i see how they're
not even pulling our heart strings
they're punching them because there's
nothing else they can do
but at the same time the odin bond isn't
there
and loki doesn't care about humanity at
this point loki
isn't invested in much besides his
mother they there are enough scenes that
reference how
the mother is the thing that unites
these brothers so it's kind of hard to
think of anything
else they could have done with the
cannon up until this point so
i can acknowledge the manipulation while
also acknowledging that where the story
was and with the benefit of timing
this movie's already clocking into two
hours long there's not much else you can
add to it without
adding a substantial amount of screen
time that would put loki and his brother
together and i do think that's essential
for the third act
the movie doesn't work without rene
russo dying by the way it's set up here
i don't love it but i do think that's
the only way the third act works i don't
disagree with that um
in some ways though i do
[Laughter]
but i'm still annoyed with it yeah i
mean i i think that what we can do
sometimes
and look it has been a trope that has
been used so many times in film history
that
maybe we just blame those movies for
using it when they could have done
something else
and now it makes us feel like it's a
trope in the mcu when we really needed
it to happen so it's all those other
movies fault
that's or the dark world it doesn't feel
fresher with killing off the mom
to help the brothers re-unite final word
on this
for me is that i completely agree with
when
tim ryan in his segment said that
visually this movie looks phenomenal i
really think a lot of those effects
still hold up and so i will give a big
tip of the cap
to throw the dark world on that front
and now it is time for us
to shift into behind the scenes talk do
we have music for that
[Music]
we certainly do and this is gonna get
really fun because i have some
trivia for the boys that i felt like we
should probably kick off with because
it's gonna be tough to talk about this
in the context of the mcu
and in even broader terms of making the
film without possibly some of these
answers being given away
and so joel i'm going to give you you
and each uh
you you and coy each have one trivia
question to ask on you to answer on your
own
and then i have a game that is going to
elate coy and frustrate the hell out of
joel so joel
give me a number between one and two
two joel picks two okay so oh good
you got a question i think you can
actually think you can get this one
and the reason he says that is because
i'm not the world's greatest
mcu expert just just to set up the
expectations because
you know people may think that in my
position i'm i'm well steeped in this
and
grew up uh knowing what a malaketh was
i did not so that sort of said i just
want to set the table stakes here
at whatever bar that your family has in
australia is there
the one behind me
sorry there is a bar behind me um there
is a bar behind it it
there is no trivia night but mark if you
were living in far north queensland
currently i'm sure we'd put one on just
for you because you would bring those
crowds
do not tempt me i am happy to
make the voyage across many ponds to get
there because it does seem like a blast
so this is joel's question for a point
joel
who is originally set to direct
thor the dark world
well i believe there are multiple people
vying for it but the person
well i'm gonna rack up some points here
uh
the big one that everyone knows i think
and that actually
signed on um was patty jenkins
the director of wonder woman uh wonder
woman 1984
vastly underrated film uh and monster um
and then i believe they decided to take
oh i'm giving i'm giving
bonus info here i guess i believe they
decided to uh
to um she decided to part ways uh when
they decided to take the story in a
different direction she had a sort of
romeo and juliet
asgard earth thing situation going on um
which i would have loved to have seen um
and she might have even had a motivation
for malachite somewhere written in her
script but it just it wasn't to be
um you are a thousand percent correct
and you get many points because i was
also going to ask you what storyline did
she want to go with and it was that
romeo and juliet vibe alan taylor uh was
vying with a another game of thrones
director for that job and alan taylor
ultimately
got it and so coy now we go to you to
tie joel
uh here's my question it's a little bit
of uh i'm to give you some leeway with
the answer here in the sequel to this
movie thor ragnarok thor mentions that
he and jane
broke up how was this handled in the
movie
uh i i believe it was just a single line
of dialogue it was it was just pure
exposition without like
no context and it was just like a don't
want to talk about it and i think it was
i think it was with loki but i'm not 100
sure okay and you you are
you're fairly correct here unless lucy
wants to weigh in
yeah so i wrote a bad question i'm sorry
specifically specific i was rashed for
time and i just pressed send and
it's a bad question okay ultimately how
did
marvel explain away
that line in thor ragnarok where the end
post-credit scene thor leaves the throne
right
and he's like oh din i don't want to be
the king and then he goes and then
he and jane are making out in that
post-credit scene so how did
marvel bridge the gap between what he
says in thor ragnarok
and well the the bonus a little extra
bonus point like the romeo and juliet
was the woman he's making out with is
actually his real-life wife because
she's the same height and looks the same
from behind as natalie portman
so the woman in the post-credits team
isn't adele portman it's his real life
life
uh which is lovely because he got to
like a passionate snog and no guilt
um yeah he got to like share a moment
with his wife in the mcu which i think
is so precious and darling
and she's fantastic in the fast and
furious films um but
i believe they explain that she's like
off doing work
on the the mysteries of the universe
from the second film like she's
she's doing studies is that is that the
the more specific answer to your
question
that sounds good to me it sounds pretty
good i think ultimately though they
they ended up doing another post-credit
scene right
they did but not in not in dark world or
uh i i give up what's the answer
well right right where are they where do
they do am i beating coy
i don't know boy on the ropes
i wrote a bad question ultimately
oh i got the question that made sense my
question is bad coy you get
points for that i i tried to answer all
the things i had context for
ultimately didn't didn't they didn't
marvel like reshoot another post-credits
scene that kind of was like
then thor and jane being like i can't be
with you
and then they break oh did they ever do
that i didn't step in here there was an
alternate ending of this
original script right yeah i don't think
they shot it but yeah they never shot it
lucy
and i'm getting bonus points again mark
for stepping in on
questions
too coy gets the point i was a breakup
oh no okay so joel there was a breakup
scene there was a breakup scene that
they wrote
but never filmed correct from my
understanding is that he did feel
so originally um he was supposed to go
up there and take the throne right
and then when the test audiences reacted
so badly to loki's death
and they decided to shoot that scene so
that loki had indeed been odin
the whole time which is i think is my
understanding of what goes on there um
they then had to give uh thor a reason
not to take the throne therefore he went
down to jane
they changed what they're originally
going to do is is is that correct
that sounds really really good and it
gives
them i'm smart but am i right in fact
thor dark world that didn't fit in the
context that was extra natalie portman
who had at this point left the mcu she
was done after dark world
but they wanted to incorporate more of
thor dark world end-to-end game for the
time travel stuff where she was still
not used
so the scene in thor in avengers end
game is actually a deleted scene from
this film where rocket goes to retrieve
the aether from her and that's why the
editing's so tricky because she like
wakes up from bed and rockets like he
but all of that was shot eight years
earlier for dark world
and that is why okay i'm gonna give koi
equal points to joel right now simply
because
all this line of questioning led to that
which is
i i mean i was lucky enough to be in a
jam theater opening night to see
avengers end game like a lot of our fans
listening
and when we saw natalie portman it's
like she's back holy crap this is
amazing the
just raucous applause nobody realizing
at the time that
that scene was from thor the dark world
but
but it also gave us some level of
maybe to a way to brace ourselves for
the news that hey
natalie portman is going to come back in
love and thunder which is going to be
the next
thor film in canon and
so i i was interested in those questions
for you guys one because i like to
torture
everybody that's on the show with some
trivia but more importantly
the fact that we now get jane foster
back in love and thunder and
it's going to have that tone that thor
ragnarok had is what it you would
obviously look like given the fact that
it's taika waititi doing it
is could we have had thor ragnarok
and that tone with the dark world or did
it simply not work yet
i think it's too big of a leap from the
first one i think we needed the darkness
of the sec i think we needed the empire
strikes back to return to the jedi
if you look at any of the trilogies if
you look at the mcu as a whole
phase one is very much a new hope phase
two is very much empire and phase three
is very much return of the jedi but
especially
the thor franchise it literally goes
from discovering you're a hero
and getting rid of your own hubris to a
dark middle saga with losing a hand to
a movie that would have ewoks in it
ragnarok could have had e-box and it
would have worked so i would argue thor
is the most like the star wars of them
and we know kevin feige has modeled the
phases like that to a point
i don't know if it would have worked we
went from kenneth branagh right to taika
i don't know if that would have
translated i also don't know if the
patty jenkins romeo and juliet would
have translated because
i think the moment where he hung up
mjolnir on the coat rack and where
the the chris evans scene all those
moments of levity made the audience
realize we really need this and i think
we needed chris hemsworth to be done
he was done with this character he was
bored there's a lot of interviews about
how he was like i didn't know where to
take him
i think we needed that level of broken
man to have the comedy be so high
because
they basically realized they cast a
comedian that just happens to look like
a god
like you you don't expect chris
hemsworth to be as funny and perfectly
comedically timed as he is they
they discovered that on the day and
we're like wait we can make a comedy
with thor
all of that like the butterfly effect of
dark world goddess ragnarok in my
opinion
joel you agree with that because that
would have been another acceptable
answer for who was set to direct the
next thor movie was
originally kenneth branagh it just he
didn't have time and
it didn't work on his timeline with his
schedule to come back and direct through
the dark world so it never really
materialized into anything oh
thank god because then we got artemis
fowl but um sorry
um uh what was it yes i agree with
everything that koi said
basically that we did we did need this
film to sort of
uh kind of be a wake-up call to what
could happen and what could happen in
phase three i think it would have been
quite a jarring tonal shift
i do think however two things when you
look at the idea of this film being so
integral to endgame
or you look at this film in its place
what it's set up for the mcu
both uh in terms of on-screen narrative
and behind the scenes of where they took
it
great that we benefited after it but
that doesn't change the film itself
like so when i i just i like to say you
can't just
retroactively say well because this film
set up all these things
and has its tendrils and all these
better films therefore the film itself
is better
no the film is still a pretty big
misfire
that just happens to have some ideas
that other people went and you know made
into more interesting compelling
products in my view
the other thing is oh sorry the other
thing i just wanted to say and
piggybacking of what koi said
and i think it's important to talk about
in this film is that yes chris hemsworth
does look like a god
and he is extremely good looking and
they make the absolute most of that in
this film
with gratuitous shirtless shots by
getting rid of that ridiculous dyed
um yellow blonde eyebrow
weird yeah they give us grungy loki
looking like i don't know he's about to
perform a vampire weekend song after his
mother's day
i'm i'm just as you know as a man who's
uh you know not not not shy of these
guardians
i i was appreciating what what was being
served in this film
and it's interesting that joel brings
that up coy because i always go back to
the bond movie
the quantum of solace where we had this
great opening with daniel craig's bonds
with uh casino royale and then quantum
of solace is you just walk out and
you're
like
what exactly does happen in that movie
and you just think well don't worry the
next one is going to explain everything
that we're still wondering about with
that
and skyfall's like no we're just going
to make a great bond movie don't worry
about quantum status so
it is hard to sometimes go back and
retroactively change how you feel about
a movie simply because of what it's set
up but if there was a movie
to be a candidate for change it sounds
like it was the dark world
well and and you know the argument that
was just given i agree with that for age
of ultron i think a lot of people give
age of ultron a lot of leeway post-war
division post endgame post infinity war
because
it had to be a connecting piece it did
the things that
iron man 2 wanted to do a little bit
better but the film as a whole if you
watch the episode
i did about that is still a lot of a
mess i would argue that dark world is at
least a cohesive thing
it's not a great thing but if you're
looking at a bell curve again back to
american academia
a c is average i would say this is a c
minus i would say it's below average but
it's still like
it put in the work and it's its own
contained thing so i don't think i think
it's unfairly maligned but
i would say this and iron man 3 are the
most unfairly maligned i think iron man
3 belongs in the top 10.
i agree this isn't the bottom three but
i'd say it's higher
in the overall scale of comic films just
because marvel's a little bit stronger
as a whole
it's i have a yeah go ahead sorry mark i
just i have a
slight side note of this and it's kind
of it's a moment i don't want to take us
off the rails but i want to pick coy's
brain because he's so smart about this
stuff and so steeped in it
um you already stole his opening line
about rotten tomatoes so
cold boy this could be appropriated for
joel frankly i'm just giving future
rotten tomatoes information just me
i'm just crown sourced trying to get
some lines to share and take credit for
but
i was watching this film and i'm curious
how it plays out in the comics um
and talking about asgardians are the
asgardians kind of evil
underneath it all like i feel like this
is a kind of
um roman empire sort of try
what why do they get to rule the realms
and why do they
get to sort of tell the elves and the
frost monster of people thingies
what to do and sort of go and travel to
their there's a scene in this movie at
the beginning where
where we're first introduced to thor
looking very thor and he's beating up
some locals in some other realm right
and i'm like i'm like they didn't even
come to you why are you guys going
around to all the
this is like the empire i feel like
asgard
is not so great and odin in this film um
although in the end it's revealed not
really because it wasn't intended this
way that he's played by loki
uh it's kind of an us like he's kind of
terrible
and then there's literally a point when
i think the like the rebels come up
and these guys are hiding in their gold
castle and i have this theory
that asgard and asgardians are actually
the evil
force in the thor films and is there any
hint of that in the comics i'm sorry
mark i went off topic
no i'm curious about this point i need
that question answered i mean
in the end it doesn't really matter
because asgard uh blew up so
you know like the death star like both
of the death stars
is asgard actually the home of most of
the bad guys
in the galaxy so that's a really fun
question because that's something
they've been dabbling with for about 60
years in the comic books because
the character well the character of thor
is actually available to
all comic booktum because it's a god so
dc can use hercules thor odin all of
those characters because
it's more of an open source character so
marvel has a really interesting task
where he's one of their avengers he's
one of their leads
so they actually look at that quite
often you've got donald blake
who in some continuities is the human
form that thor takes on to learn
humility
and they actually hinted that in the
first film with him taking on that that
joke monitor as a scientist in the first
film so
there's a lot of commentary on how
humanity sees the gods because
when he takes on that role of humility
he remembers his past and how he
perceived himself
and you start to wonder if that
arrogance is actually how the gods
perceive themselves you've also got the
elements of
this whole thing this this arc is
largely based on the jason aaron run and
he's one of the longest running writers
on thor of all time uh he wrote thor for
over eight years and he's currently
writing some jane foster valkyrie stuff
that's genius
but it's it's a lot about how the space
cops
are basically the asgardians they're
they're this ruling dictatorship
and what line is there in control versus
peace
what line is there in manipulation as a
god versus taking control
so are the dark elves in the right are
the are the other elves on the right are
the
are the frost giants in the right
because it does seem like these gods
come out and say like hey this is our
way or no way
and if you look at the the parents of
greek gods like hercules
zeus um i mean zeus especially just kind
of put his dick in anything and that
caused all the problems in that entire
mythology
but odin also does that a lot like
odin's kind of a problematic character
so
when you look at loki playing odin it
was really fun for me to see anthony
hopkins just kind of chewing the scenery
because
that character does work as a scenery
chewing character even if it hadn't been
loki because
odin's not the best guy so i would argue
the commentary on
absolute power corrupting absolutely is
especially important for the asgardians
and it's kind of like having an eye line
you always want the eye line of the
audience to be your hero
otherwise they become your antagonist so
with thor being our eye line the nuance
of what it means for him to be human
what it means for him to be an avenger
and what it means for him to be a god
are the three perspectives you're
dealing with and i think that's the
reason he wasn't in civil war
because if you look at the ark of the
mcu phase one to phase three the center
point is civil war and when you talk to
the writers they'll tell you that was
kind of the cross and the x where
you have the end of the mcu ending with
tony making the selfless choice
cap making the selfish choice and at the
beginning of the mcu
tony's the one that's making bombs caps
the one that's jumping on on the grenade
and that crossover happens in civil war
thor's not there because he's on a
walkabout his experience of what it
means to be human
is him losing himself and that's what
infinity war and endgame really
represent i think that's why he's the
best character to have four films and
beyond why it's good for him to be in
guardians
because his arc is never concluded
because are the asgardians good or bad
is an experience that we have through
thor
of what it means to be a good man and
that's why the character's so
interesting is we're looking at this as
ourselves
what does it mean to be human what does
it mean to be good so you're saying you
put some thought into this
i'm stealing everything yes it's just
every bit of that i'm gonna see this as
an
article and be like this guy really
knows his mythology yeah i i look i i
think honestly koi you are now the
the the crowd hype you're the you're the
warm-up act
for any time joel has to give a speech
in front of the
the corporate bigwigs because that was
oh no i'm not following that
impression you may want to have koi be
the headliner he's my ghost
the world's reopening you guys are down
the street anytime i will do 25
mcu properties line them up i'm ready i
actually introduced this film for the
russo brothers at the the 23 and the
road to end game uh
at the lcap so they had they had these
films being introduced yeah and people
knew
that i was one of the rare dark world
defenders so
i got to introduce winter soldier which
is my favorite film guardians which is
my second favorite film
this film falls right between the iron
man 3 era so i got to
and they set this at three in the
morning because they expected people to
sleep through it so i came out and gave
like a
for asgard speech because this film is
so important
and it was really cool to be recognized
by kevin feige and the russo brothers
for
understanding why this film is important
and uh yeah the thor mythology means so
much to me especially from the comic
books so that's
i have put some thought into it could
not have picked a better guest or a
better uh co-host to book for this
particular episode and i take
none of that credit thank you to lucy
and i do have one more trivia question
just to break the tie but we're going to
get to that on the other side
of our mailbag segment we got a quick
one today but we still get music
[Music]
chris quarry says jennifer's body
feminist masterpiece or schwack
okay good question there for general we
are the perfect
panel to answer this question i have to
say jordan
my fellow white men let's let's discuss
this
film from karen kusama um
well i will say about this film that i
like it
a lot i think it is incredibly
underrated uh it features in a little
book
called rotten movies we love where the
argument is
precisely made that not only is it
potentially a feminist
masterpiece but it's a good damn time
and it's really smart and i think what's
really and
you know i think sorry i'm gonna i'm i'm
i'm off now but
the thing that did underserve this film
was the marketing of it in many ways
that poster of megan fox uh really
selling it as something that it wasn't
that got a lot of teenage boys into that
theater expecting something altogether
different
having only seen megan in transformers
um and then getting that poster of the
image and what they got was a more
interesting challenge the horror genre
that's really entertaining um and
features a very good performance from
megan fox
uh a very underrated and unfairly
maligned performance from megan fox
she's so great in it feminist
masterpiece not my place to say
good film absolutely you're right i mean
the combination of megan fox on the
poster and the movie title
being jennifer's body it kind of you can
understand why some
some teenagers might have gone awry
walking in
to that movie so i did promise that i
had one more trivia question
and this could break the time i got an
answer can i can i speak on jennifer's
body briefly
you can speak on anything you want coy
you're the new editor-in-chief so yes
you can say whatever you want
i would argue jennifer's body is one of
those examples where knowing too much
about someone's personal stuff they're
going through
hurt the film because this was when we
were objectifying megan fox
completely and it was awful and that
poor woman was hounded by paparazzi and
she was seen as this thing she didn't
want to be seen as because she needed to
market other films
she was unfairly attacked for the things
she said about michael bay that then
were
seemingly found true so i would say this
is one of those times where
this was on the cusp of the full
exposure to where now
movie stars are going away because
everyone's trying to be a movie star and
everyone's five minutes on youtube is
taking away from the grandiose nature of
what
seeing someone as an icon was in the up
until the 80s we had a
we had a separation from viewer to movie
and that had its own problems too but i
would say this was in that transition
period where
everyone knew everything about everyone
everyone's drama was everywhere everyone
dating someone was more important than
their movie being released so
it wasn't an opportunity for it to be
seen as the feminist masterpiece
that it i would say it was but i'm also
not the right person to
quantify that but i think that it was
trying to subvert expectations in a time
where that wasn't available for that
poor actress who's now seen as much more
of a force than she was seen as then and
it should be
said that it was spoke like the title's
ironic in a way and that
wasn't an option because of how it was
marketed so i think it's unfair because
the marketing because of how much we are
in megan fox's business and because of
how we
let people walk all over women back then
and i think we're working on that now
and i think now would be seen much
better
good answers from both of you yeah i had
my five minutes on youtube phase and now
i get a whole hour show to talk about
whatever movies i feel like pivoting to
but we do have to break this trivia tie
so very quickly here is the question and
pay attention to it because it could be
tricky what was the first on-screen
appearance
of the character thor not limited
to the mcu whoever's interested in
babysitting
joel mears gets it and for a bonus point
who played thor in that movie vincent's
and offroad kingpin vincent d'onofrio
shows up in a cameo says truck driver
thor because the little girl wants to be
thor
in adventures in babysitting which of
course has the best babysitter
performance i'm looking at you mary
poppins of all time
with elizabeth shoe can i confess
something please
there's a reason i know that uh i know
it because i know it but there's a
reason i knew it so quickly
was because just yesterday it's one of
my jobs as the editor-in-chief of rotten
tomatoes to review
all the video that is about to be put
onto our over-the-top
channel a channel you can find on the
roku channel
uh and it's called the rotten tomatoes
channel go seek it out
but you'll see mark ellis there often
doing little interstitial uh chats and
things
cory might have done the answer i don't
know i was good in there and
yesterday as i was reviewing them little
one-minute snippets of mark just giving
his sort of fireside chat thoughts
he went off on a tangent about the
adventures of babysitting
specifically citing thor specifically
singling out vincent d'onofrio
so it's very fresh in my mind this scene
like there was an insider trading a rock
tomatoes i feel like
he had no idea this was coming he had no
he had no idea i've seen that
yeah well i mean look boy you did get a
new job and a big promotion today so i
think it's fair that yeah i've lost my
job the cost
it's worth it i'd say it's fair overall
joel loses his job but wins the trivia
here on rotten tomatoes is wrong
so thank you both for for joining me and
just a great conversation that i
i whenever we get us all in a room we
have great talks about movies but
when you give me throw the dark world
you say okay well how where are we going
with this movie
this was so much fun and coy i know you
got a lot of big things in the oven
right now you can't talk about all of
them
but coy cass is is that the best place
for folks to find you currently and all
the stuff that you got going on
so coy cast is on anywhere you get your
podcast koi cubed is my youtube channel
that i started the beginning of
quarantine because
uh mark and i are usually at studios
together but then you know the world
stopped so i had to learn what obs was
by watching a lot of 12 year olds on
youtube and feeling very bad about
myself
uh so i have a youtube for all my news
outlet stuff so anywhere you type in
my name there's some format of me
getting stuff to you because i
it's like a bag of cats up here in the
words of loki i have so much
i want to share with folks so movies
comics anything pop culture
a little bit too much politics i really
love the experience of the the fandom
and how much
i used to hide my spider-man shirt and
now i can wear it with pride so
hunt me down because i love this stuff
so very much and you have a movie
recommendation for us that maybe is
somewhere in the vein of thor the dark
world for
all the kids to check out uh you know if
they haven't seen it they probably have
but i i think the closest thing to dark
world is i want to reference
chris hemsworth's when he got cast as
thor cabin in the woods
is is regarded well but it can never be
overhyped because
that movie is a meta-modernist
masterpiece it understands exactly what
it is
it really gets better with age
especially in a post-pandemic world it's
gonna be really interesting to look back
on that isolation
the cast is perfect and uh chris
hemsworth was cast
during the filming of that film and put
on so much muscle that if you watch the
film closely there's actually scenes
where they had to resize his shirt
because his neck got bigger
so while they were filming hemsworth got
so big that they had to change the
wardrobe on an indie film for the god of
thunder so it is
a masterwork and joss whedon didn't know
he was going to be thor so it just so
happens to be produced by joss
and then he worked on the universe later
so there's a lot of fun synchronicity
with cap in the woods if you haven't
seen it it is genius
i just hate when my neck gets all jacked
and i gotta buy different clothes it
really
really puts a damper on my week uh great
performance today
by our returning champion coy jandrew as
well as from joel mears joel i want to
give you the floor real quick too
what are you working on right now rotten
tomatoes uh other projects you got going
on you mentioned rotten tomatoes
the book that we have uh that is
currently available everywhere now i
imagine at some point we might get a
sequel to rotten movies we love the book
and if you have coy right the forward i
just want to warn you it's going to look
like a
harry potter tone because it's going to
go from here to here it's going to be a
big big long forward
right and i'm going to put my name
directly underneath it
now we may we may have another book in
the works i'm just i don't think i'm
allowed to officially announce anything
yet but we we're very honorable
and then we have an introduction written
by me slash koi um but that is what we
do
we've got a few things we've got
obviously this wonderful podcast as i
mentioned we've got the rotten tomatoes
channel which you can find on roku
so many things follow us on rotten
tomatoes at rotten tomatoes across all
your great social media
um platforms i guess we say
um shout out to things you should watch
don't watch this show but
home and away is the best breeding
ground for future superstars home away
is an australian soap opera
uh where mr hemsworth got his start
along with a bunch of other
uh awesome australians uh that you know
from melissa george to ryan quanton and
all these other sun-soaked hotties um
but if you're looking for a
film or tv recommendation uh i believe
the timing of when this podcast lands
will be around the time of
in the heights or in the heights is
coming out in about a week and that film
is an absolute
blast and you should absolutely go and
see it and dance in the aisles
in theaters if it's safe and if you're
staying home
i suggest watching season two of feel
good
and watch season one i feel good as well
which has the wonderful may martin
comedian based
in the uk canadian though really really
smart
uh a netflix gem that i don't think gets
the attention it quite deserves
there you go some great recommendations
and lucy make sure that we
uh re-book joel for some appearance
coming up when he can talk about maybe
that
mystery book that he teased us with so
y'all can email us
like i said rt is wrong at
rottentomatoes.com if you have
thoughts on what movies we should be
talking about opinions on what movie we
just did talk about we love hearing from
our fans from our listeners from our
certified fresh ketchup crew
please let us know what movies you want
us to talk about on future episodes of
rotten tomatoes is wrong
you can subscribe rate review wherever
you enjoy podcast do whatever that
platform encourages you to do to get us
up in the numbers
we love love love when you share us with
your family with your friends because at
the end of the day
we're just celebrating movies and why we
love them
so four the great editor-in-chief of
rotten tomatoes joel
mears the host of coy cass and koi cube
coy jandrew
sterling performance by both gentlemen
today i was merely along for the ride
producer lucy who is back with us once
again we love her so much christian
rubicon
brian perez the entire team here at
rotten tomatoes and for my co-host
jacqueline coley
i am merely mark ellis saying thank you
and we'll catch you next week
[Music]
you